[Musica]
buonasera
oggi voglio parlarvi del paradosso
dell'informazione che è una questione
che ha diviso la comunità dei fisici
nell'ultimo secolo ma ha portato anche a
intuizioni molto profonde su come
funziona il nostro universo
e vorrei condividerne qualcuna con voi
bene la prima cosa da fare però è capire
cosa intendiamo noi fisici quando
parliamo di paradosso vedete un
paradosso in fisica e quando due leggi
che noi consideriamo ben testate e
accertate sono in disaccordo sulla
risposta a un quesito che noi poniamo
che sostanzialmente vuol dire che non
abbiamo idea di cosa stia accadendo bene
quali sono queste due leggi il nostro
caso
da una parte la relatività generale di
einstein che spiega la forza di gravità
come la curvatura di un tessuto spazio
temporale che ci circonda dall'altra la
meccanica quantistica
ma procediamo con ordine
bene dalla relatività generale voglio
prendere il concetto di un buco nero
fine mi sono oggetti estremamente
interessanti e quindi iniziamo a vedere
come si formano e cos'è un buco nero
vedete i buchi neri si formano tramite
un processo chiamato collasso
gravitazionale quando una stella e
invita vive in una sorta di equilibrio
da un lato la forza di gravità vuole
comprimerla dall'altro la fusione
nucleare
al suo interno cerca di farle esplodere
ed è in equilibrio fino a che un certo
punto finisce il carburante il
carburante che alimenta la fusione e
inizia quindi a collassare quando la
stella è molto grossa si parla di almeno
due volte la massa del sole gli strati
più interni precipitano e formano questo
oggetto chiamato appunto
un buco nero ora i buchi neri hanno
tantissime proprietà interessanti ma noi
interessa quello che succede sul loro
bordo sul loro parte più esterna ecco
che a questo nome si chiama l'orizzonte
degli eventi è un nome molto altisonante
ma ha un motivo infatti vedete quando
qualsiasi cosa qualsiasi forma di massa
ed energia attraversa l'orizzonte degli
eventi rimane intrappolata per sempre
nel buco nero
il buco nero è una specie di pozzo
gravitazionale una delle bisonte degli
eventi fa di più infatti esso nasconde
nel proprietà del buco nero
cosa intendo intendo che se noi
osserviamo un buco nero
le uniche cose che possiamo capire sono
la sua massa stato da quanto è grosso
la sua carica elettrica che però non ci
interessa molto e la velocità con cui
ruota tutto il resto è celato quindi lo
risultato di 20 a una specie di censore
cosmico
ma c'è di più vedete per molto tempo
pensavamo che i buchi neri fossero
oggetti e terni
un giorno stephen hawking è arrivato è
il modo molto elegante ha dimostrato che
i buchi neri evaporano cosa intendo per
evaporano intendo che col tempo molto
molto lentamente e mettono questa
radiazione elettromagnetica in questa
radiazione si porta via energia del buco
nero si porta via la sua massa del buco
nero rimpicciolisce e rimpicciolisce
sempre più velocemente fino a svanire
ok ora sappiamo quello che ci interessa
i buchi neri
mettiamolo da parte un attimo abbiamo
detto che nel evaporano
e i buchi neri agiscono come una specie
di censura cosmica
tra l'altro noi fisici diciamo che i
buchi neri non hanno peli
per questo motivo qua andiamo all'altra
faccia del paradosso l'informazione
quantistica l'informazione quantistica è
un concetto che viene dalla branca della
fisica chiamata appunto meccanica
quantistica
ed è un concetto abbastanza astratto un
po difficile da spiegare senza l'uso di
formule quindi voglio portarvi
degli esempi per cercare di farvi capire
perché è molto importante
immaginate gli altri di carbonio gli
atomi di carbonio sono completamente
identici fra di loro
eppure noi sappiamo che possono formare
oggetti estremamente diversi dalle
proprietà estremamente diverse dai
diamanti alla grafite che avete nelle
matite ma anche oggetti scostante
materiali più moderni come il grafene un
superconduttore estremamente resistente
ma se tutti questi materiali sono fatti
dello stesso identico tipo di atomo
cos'è che li distingue cos'è che gli da
le loro proprietà ma il modo in cui
questi atomi sono disposti tra di loro
vedete questo è in un certo senso
l'informazione quantistica
l'informazione quantistica è tutto
l'insieme delle proprietà che dà a un
sistema fisico appunto le sue
caratteristiche è perché ci interessa
così tanto perché l'informazione
quantistica ha una proprietà unica è
indistruttibile l'informazione
quantistica qualsiasi cosa noi facciamo
il nostro sistema fisico non può mai
essere distrutta cosa vuol dire
immaginate di avere un foglio di carta
con un messaggio e di bruciarlo
tecnicamente è una situazione
irrecuperabile però dal punto di vista
teorico se voi riuscisse a raccogliere
tutte le molecole di gas tutte le
molecole di cenere qui questo foglio era
composto potreste ricostruire sia il
foglio che il messaggio
questo per dire che una traccia dello
stato di un sistema fisico rimane sempre
durante le sue trasformazioni e qui
arriviamo alla chiave abbiamo i due lati
del paradosso
qual è la domanda è la domanda che i
fisici si sono posti è cosa succede
all'informazione che cade dentro un buco
nero e perché questo è interessante bene
immaginate di avere 50 kg di diamanti e
vi avanzano e di buttarli dentro un buco
nero poi di misurare questo buco nero e
vedrete che effettivamente la sua massa
è aumentata di 50 kg
ma per le proprietà che vi ho spiegato
prima delle orizzonte degli eventi non
potrete mai capire se avete votato dei
diamanti avete votato della grafite
avete votato della plastica qualsiasi
altra cosa per cui dove va a finire
questa informazione è questa domanda che
ha spaccato la comunità dei fisici per
molti anni da una parte i relativisti
dicevano informazione persa l'ampia nica
quantistica va ripensata d'altra parte i
sostenitori della fisica quantistica
invece dicevano che no
da qualche parte questa informazione
deve finire deve andare non può svanire
nel nulla
bene ora i dettagli della risoluzione
del paradosso si stanno ancora decidendo
però abbiamo già capito molto molto di
più su cosa succede effettivamente
vedete immaginate di essere sul bordo di
uno stagno uno stagno profondo e di
prendere un sasso e buttarlo dentro
man mano che il sasso affonda e scompare
la vostra vista voi non potrete più fare
niente per misurarlo perdete le
informazioni a riguardo
e invece no perché se voi potesse
misurare la forma e l'ampiezza e la
velocità con cui questo salso ha creato
delle increspature se voi poteste
misurare le increspature sull'acqua
saresti in grado di capire un sacco di
informazioni su questo roccia che è
caduta dovesse capire la sua forma la
velocità con cui entrata la sua massa la
sua energia
ecco in questo senso l'informazione del
sasso viene dipinta sulla superficie
dello stagno ed è allo stesso modo che
quando la materia di energia entrano in
un buco nero una traccia del loro
passaggio rimane dipinta sull'orizzonte
degli eventi
dopodiché la radiazione quando viene
messa e se ne vanno l'universo porta con
sé in questa informazione informazioni e
quindi salva e viene restituita dal
luogo in cui è venuta bene direte voi
abbiamo risolto paradosso beh in un
certo senso sì ma il punto è
ancora più profondo vedete i fisici si
sono accorti che questo aveva delle
mense ancora più profonde
se prendete un buco nero è un volume
tridimensionale
eppure come vi ho appena spiegato
l'informazione di tutto ciò che contiene
è scritta sulla sua superficie che è una
area bidimensionale cosa vuol dire vuol
dire che il buco nero funziona un po
come un ologramma
se avete presente quelle carte che
alcuni di noi avevano da piccoli sono
immagini bidimensionali eppure se le
guardate viene proiettata un'immagine
con una dimensione in più sembra entrati
ora quella un'illusione ottica mentre io
sto parlando di dati quantistici
ma se buchi neri funziona come degli
ologrammi sono chiesti fisici perché non
potrebbe essere l'universo stesso che
funziona un ologramma
e se fosse che tutte le informazioni su
tutto quello che succede all'interno del
nostro universo non fosse altro che una
immagine bidimensionale distantissima da
noi ma vedete questo probabilmente non
sapremo mai però i fisici hanno
costruito dei modelli simili li chiamano
modelli di gravità olografica o universi
in scatola e questo ha portato a
grandissimi sviluppi anzi si è aperto un
intero campo che studia questo genere di
fenomeni e di conseguenza quello con cui
voglio lasciarvi è un po l'idea che come
i fisici che studiavano avevano bloccati
su questo paradosso dell'informazione si
sono poi resi conto che il nocciolo
della questione era in realtà se
l'universo 1 grammo oppure no a volte
anche noi quando siamo bloccati su un
problema invece di continuare a buttarci
energie
forse dovremmo chiederci se ci stiamo
facendo la giusta domanda
grazie mille
[Applauso]
[Musica]